but the UK set to formally leave the
European Union the government will now
focus on their next phase of
negotiations getting a trade deal and
forging a new partnership with the
remaining 27 countries based on the
existing deadline the UK and EU now have
11 months to come up with a deal which
according to the UK government is going
to mean tariff free and duty-free trade
in goods during this time the transition
period the UK retains access to the
single market and the customs union the
EU is hoping to have its negotiating
mandate approved by its ministers on the
25th of February a m-- of launching
negotiations within the first few days
of March in June there will be a meeting
between the UK and the EU to see just
how much progress has been made that
will happen in June and then the UK has
until the 1st of July 2020 to request an
extension to the transition period after
12 or maybe 24 months Boris Johnson
though has said he's got no intention of
extending the transition period EU
officials say if there's a deal to be
done it has to be presented to the
European Parliament by November the 26th
so it could be ratified by the end of
the year remember every EU member state
gets a vote on that deal Boris Johnson
says he wants a comprehensive free trade
agreement but the EU has said it may
only be a bare-bones deal because of
time constraints the transition period
ends on the 31st of December of this
year if there's no trade deal in place
the UK will trade under WTO terms
meaning tariffs and border checks so
that no deal cliff edge hasn't gone away
altogether and since major trade deals
tend to take years rather than months to
negotiate there's a good chance there'll
be outstanding issues after the end of
this year so one way or another talks
are expected to continue